nobody Scott's alien has a really unique
look and feel to it I think it's this
kind of very distinctive seventies view
of the future I think you know it's kind
of taking elements from from 50s and 60s
popular culture view of what it would be
like to live in the future but makes it
and was filters it through this kind of
70s slightly disillusioned filter of the
future so it's not that it's not this
sort of shiny idealized view of the
future it's it's very grounded and
coyote and every day and I think that's
one of the things that makes it work
within the kind of context of horror
because you know there's with the alien
it's less extraordinary and and so
unusual but it takes place in something
that's it's obviously set in the future
but something we can kind of relate to
and I think in the production that
designers is you know he's really
showing or defining I think you know
both films and games I've borrowed from
it in the past and I think that was the
exciting thing for us was you know for
the first time it felt like someone had
actually gone back to that original
source material and and you know
effectively based a game upon it from
the outset it was this kind of thrilling
idea of what would it be like to
experience being in a space with Ridley
Scott's alien the alien in the first
film presents something that is totally
unique way you know the tone of it is
just well you know that there's a
there's a crew and just one alien deadly
enough the kind of effectively wipes out
the entire crew and I think that's an S
that was the starting point for us was
you know what would it be like to play a
game where one alien would represent
this meaningful interaction to the
player that would be there'd be
terrifying believable a sense that was
incredibly intelligent it was hunting
you down
you know we kind of asked ourselves the
question you know if we released that
alien in the studio right now what would
you do you know no really what would you
do and you know if this kind of
conversation went around this sort of
idea of you know trying to get behind
tables and under tables and make sure
you couldn't be seen and you know and
then you'd you know and then we throw in
okay we need to get to the fire escape
or whatever you know and how you gonna
do that you know okay I'm gonna wait to
you know we're gonna try and try and
peek and see if I can see it and then
you know and I think that's let's sort
of just from that kind of early
conversations we talked early on about
wanting to really and the aliens have
really reestablish it as as this kind of
monolithic terrifying domineering force
and I think that's been our kind of goal
from the start
you know one of the things a lien
represents is this kind of sense of a
serious sci fi that it's it's it's right
where the rules the world are
established early on but it's it's very
much about people it's about a human
story and actually the the the sci-fi
tech the sort of technology is really
downplayed and I think that the what's
interesting about that is is it saying
that technology isn't the answer people
are the answer one of the great things
about alien is has this very small
ensemble cast of people who have come
from different motivations and different
agendas but they have different goals
themselves but their relationships cause
tension and of course when when the
alien appears there's kind of those
relationships get pulled apart and and
and reformed and that's something that
we've tried to mirror that we have a
relatively small cast in in alien
isolation and there's a group of people
you get to know but of course events
occur and how they react to those events
you know they they all react differently
to these events and you know sometimes
they're positive sometimes they're
negative towards play so we really
wanted the player to feel like they were
they were underpowered and underprepared
you know we realized early on we didn't
want a kind of constant motion tracker
you know this kind of magic radar that
would just give you too much information
and so we wanted something that the
players actively used wouldn't be just
this passive box that will give you
information that you actually actively
consciously seek out the information
then at the same time I was really keen
for every action to have some kind of
cost or risk associated with it so the
motion tracker we have in the alien
isolation does give you some information
but when you when you're aiming it and
looking at it it blurs the background
and so that reduces the information you
can see in the background we allow you
to toggle so you can
look at the background but then it blurs
the foreground and so there's this nice
trade-off you have to actively decide to
use the mesh checker and then actively
decide to use it's a make a decision as
to what what and when you're gonna
you're looking at so I think one of the
the important decisions we made early on
was to to not have the alien running
under any prescribed paths or patterns
that it would just be using its sensors
to try and hunt the player down I think
that kind of feeds into you know I think
that a large component of horror is is
the unknown is not having the
information you know information is
power and we're trying to keep the power
the player got an underpowered and so
you know I think what's what's kind of
fascinating for us is that we've been
working on this boat for three years and
we still die and we still get caught out
and I know we know you know
there is to know about this thing as we
created it and we know what's going on
under the hood but you know we're
playing it every day and yet it will
still catch us you know off-guard and do
things that we weren't predicting or
expecting and I think that's you know
that's this feels quite a magical thing
for us that you know we're so familiar
with it and yet we wish to it cause I
don't you know our heart start racing
it's great sorry only an isolation is on
Xbox 360 Xbox one PlayStation 4
PlayStation 3 and PC is coming out late
2014